she believed in God had an encounter
with Jesus and then became a high
ranking they were training her got it to
be a High um Satanist and you know she
she had she saw demons she had
encounters she she went through rape M
they even killed one of her babies in in
when she got pregnant as a sacrifice so
the crazy the story is crazy like it
made her get an abortion or like after
they took the baby out and they killed
in front of her so there there's these
things are real these things are real
and I'm like but but this is why the
enemy doesn't kind of like want to make
us think that this is not real so we
don't stand and we speak about these
matters we speak about these things and
what are we going to do against that
because if the church doesn't know that
this is real the church is just going to
be sitting